mercedes-benz vans has presented its new
X class stylish explore concept car in
Stockholm along with a powerful engine
the new premium pick up offers high
driving comfort and safety it's also
touted as robust and suited for offroad
use but why combine premium and pick up
and pick up daimler's chairman of the
board d dissension says premium pickup
is the only segment the company hasn't
covered yet and it's an important
segment that Daimler wants to move into
in the future so intimate gets to come
show bunkin along with powerful
adventure mercedes has produced another
slightly changed concept the stylish
explorer
Gooden visas in ether said she points
out that Daimler is presenting two
concept cars that's what's special about
this pick up on the one hand is
positioned as a classic traditional
vehicle for car buyers who want to
transport cargo in the country but on
the other hand it has strong lifestyle
appeal you can drive it to the Opera
Daimler is presenting this combination
as the salient feature of both concept
cars guided is the plans to unite
production in one vehicle with several
versions Edmund I'm thoughts of machine
Alliance acoustics in the product co and
done finding Daimler expects the ex
class pickups primary markets to be
Latin America and South Africa and
Europe Germany will play a major role
the truck makes for private driving fun
with the family or friends and
commercial use in one vehicle
amox fixed Edith said she says the
market is growing fast from two million
customers to a projected 2.8 million by
the year twenty twenty-five he says now
is the perfect time to enter this market
for a rosy future perfect at idea the
concept x-class aims to set new
standards for comfort safety and design
in the midsize pickup segment the top
model will have a v6 diesel engine and
the 4matic permanent all-wheel drive a
22 inch metal alloy wheels and
anthracite chrome underscore the premium
look of the stylish Explorer
in the interior are brown nubuck leather
white nappa leather and decorative oaken
aluminum details and pure luxury Gordon
etat so the Daimler executive says the
company wanted to develop a vehicle that
stands out from the crowd and gives the
pickup segment a powerful whiff of
premium and he think it has succeeded
with this design and this technology
that belong to them the powerful
adventure is a real workhorse it's
brawny design commands immediate respect
the wheel wells are not made of plastic
but matte carbon fiber the electric
winch on the front catches the eye and
says this car can move mountains the
rectangular rear with a trailer hitch
also stands for strength and durability
there are carbon fiber components in the
interior to the color accents harmonized
with the exteriors green paint I gloss
black nappa leather and green decorative
stitching round out the overall
appearance Mercedes will build the X
class pick up jointly with a
renault-nissan alliance the basic
technology and the production will be
shared with this son's navara production
begins in 2017 in the Nissan Plant and
Barcelona we can't wait to see what
Mercedes unveils in the late 2017
yeah this runny lipstick will be testing
the new subaru WRX STI a fresh version
of an old friend he's owned two from the
first generation the subaru WRX STI has
always stood out from the crowd that
starts with a huge rear spoiler see
yalls and continues in front with a
large air scoop that supplies the
intercooler with fresh air now Ronnie is
going to put this machine through its
paces on the road official of picant new
las vidas p smile of admin and cooking
lots of things office classic on
the world's biggest manufacturer of all
wheel drive cars Subaru is best known
for its victories and the world rally
championship or WRC at first one in 1995
with colin mcrae at the wheel of a
Subaru Impreza 555 our all-wheel drive
test car is 4th generation and bears the
name WRX STI
las nubes oh nothing ronnie is
especially pleased with the new STI
steering which gives him all the
feedback from the road he could want for
someone used to smoother but squishier
steering it might take some getting used
to it's extremely direct doctors to
thank all who glove is direct the STI is
two and a half litre turbocharged boxer
engine produces 221 kilowatts the
Japanese rally car launches from 0 to
100 km/h in just 5.2 seconds OSH busted
Ronnie says driving fun is in the
foreground with a new STI the boxer
engine puts out loads of power that's
like vagina vons and scuffed the engine
develops 407 newton meters of torque at
4000 revs a minute all courtesy of the
big turbocharger
the Subaru looks sporty to STI stands
for subaru tecnica international Subarus
house tuner LED headlights and black
18-inch light alloy wheel rims are
standard equipment even from a distance
you can't miss the big rear spoiler
which says this monster means business a
third brake light is integrated in the
diffuser
does a bobble big Ronnie admiringly
calls the WRX STI a rally car for the
road what you might not expect from a
car like this is the roomie trunk it has
enough storage space to take supplies
and luggage for the whole family on a
rally weekend and the recent version of
the WRX can indeed be seen at rallies
but this Subaru displays its qualities
on country roads as well the technology
of the new WRX STI isn't much different
from that of the first generation says
Ronnie he can still change the driving
mode or differential by pushing a button
the feature was introduced in 1994 and
Ronnie still likes it feature the
competition will have trouble matching
Subarus level a bang for your buck and
the sports equipment line we tested the
WRX STI costs just over 46,000 euros in
Germany it has an automatically dimming
inside rearview mirror blind spot and
lane change assists and a rain sensor
the interior comes with an audio system
by Parman cardin a backup camera heated
seats and a navigation system
the wolfsburg Volkswagen has unveiled
its facelifted Gulf the big update
brings a sharper design digital
instruments in a new infotainment system
that can be operated using gestures
optional in the new Gulf are partially
automated driving functions for example
the new traffic jam assist which
automatically applies the brakes and
stop and go traffic Audi provides a
glimpse of the coming spring with
convertible versions of its 85 and s5
models and the s5 sport version the
elegant soft top is powered by a 260
kilowatt turbocharged v6 engine and
all-wheel-drive a longer wheelbase and
more compact seats mean more room for
passengers the two variants will arrive
at European dealerships in March
the VW scirocco is a 2+2 coupe a based
on the gulf the first generation dates
back to nineteen seventy-four the second
generation ended production in 1992 and
2008 with a third generation volkswagen
breathe new life into its desert wind
dis yoko car tester on tight Zimmerman
identifies the Scirocco as his very
favorite model among vw's current ranch
mainly because it departs from many of
the core values VW seemed to stand for
nowadays every w's generally provide
lots of space inside but even after
you've squeezed into this one you may
still feel a bit cramped piston Bank
[ __ ] but it's more a subjective
feeling at least in front objectively
anyone 1 meter 85 or under shouldn't
have any problems that's just over six
feet tall we tested the Scirocco our
production model with a 2-liter TDI
engine under the hood it puts out 135
kilowatts of power consuming 4.7 litres
of fuel per hundred kilometers android
points out that even if the Scirocco
seems like a tight fit one getting in
after a few meters you feel almost like
a part of the car man fruit is cause ii
VI entire from guns the Scirocco slow
flying frame comes into its own in the
handling the low center of gravity
reduces pitch and roll and the lower
seats give the car a sporty a ride
this Yoko Andre feels that the Scirocco
is brimming with character and emotion
and that makes it more fun to drive a
highlight for him is the three extra
instruments atop the dash the boost
pressure gauge for example though he
sees it more as a gimmick that loses its
appeal after a few kilometers there's
also a gauge for oil temperature he says
VW can integrate these things in almost
any car but it's especially important in
the sports models where the driver needs
to know when the engines heating up and
when he or she can go for maximum
performance well I Singapore can
our test car included the optional
multifunction sports steering wheel the
sport package costs around 600 euros
extra
the diesel aundrea surprised how much
fun it is to drive the diesel in his
test car after 2100 revs it brings out
the steam hammer as he says but
typically for a diesel the last thousand
revs of 4000 or higher are more or less
hot air otherwise it packs a punch tamia
highest aloft a bar alastair for max
from Dominguez pass
the Scirocco ziadi design clearly
expresses more emotional than practical
considerations the windshield areas are
relatively small and the roofline slopes
down toward the rear
the Scirocco widely flared rear fenders
leave no doubt that this is a sporty
model and give a strong hint that the
cargo space behind the small hatch and
high rear lip is likely to be minimal
deshi jaco is andre decides the Scirocco
is the volkswagen for individualists for
people who value designed more than
practicality even so he's left with a
bland taste in his mouth and wondering
the thief inherently practical VW can
ever be truly emotional to rubber ducks
auto tester eNOS Petrie will use these
toys as a comparison today as she puts
the newness on Juke through its paces
business on subcompact crossover SUV is
stylish sassy and compact the Jukes
distinctive design attracted a lot of
attention when the car made its debut at
international auto shows in 2010 this
sum has made some small improvements to
the Jukes exterior for example to the
two-tier headlights our duck testers
love the Jukes bright color and its
overall styling
sporty flowing lines on top and sweeping
fender flares down below at first glance
it looks like the Juke has just two
doors it's actually got four but you can
hardly see the rear door handles because
they're perfectly integrated into the
overall design
inna says the sloping roofline cuts down
on Headroom in the back seat that could
be uncomfortable for tall people but
it's not a problem for the Ducks the
tail lights complement the Jukes narrow
on top wider on the bottom design and
this new version of the Juke has a lot
more trunk space than previous models
did
the juke that we're testing has a 1.2
liter engine with a power output of 85
kilowatts it's the smaller of the two
gasoline-powered options offered by
Nissan
our test car made it from 0 to 100 km/h
and ten point eight seconds the Juke can
reach a top speed of 178 km/h
vitesse Tina Tina says the 1.2 liter
gasoline engine is a recent innovation
for this model it's the smallest on
offer our Juke came equipped with a
6-speed manual transmission and an
integrated control system that features
three driving modes sport normal and eco
so you can adjust to different Road
conditions those integrated systems are
usually found on much more expensive
cars the interior is well designed it
looks good and it's functional this son
has reduced the number of buttons that
you have to push then ena says she
really likes the interiors design
because it matches the overall shape of
the car you can see that here in the
console and these buttons have two
functions click once and you can set the
climate control click again and you can
choose one of the three driving modes
I've seen the farm odium ass mouth penis
likes the all-round visibility the
driver sits up high and that gives you a
good view of the road and when you look
out over the hood you can see the tops
of the headlights move unless you
brothers nothing it's kind of difficult
to get a full view out the rear window
because of the sloping roofline and the
vertical supports but you can't get
around that by switching on the camera
which will give you a full outside view
and then those not to list for engine is
perfect now end of me this is an ideal
home for our to test ducks and it looks
like they fell in love with a joke at
first sight and that's often how people
decide to buy a car to find out in Sidon
the manufacturer's suggested retail
price for the base model Juke is 15,000
870 euros in Germany the fully equipped
version we tested sells for just under
twenty three thousand today our classy
car expert Christoph Bauer is taking an
unusual American car out for a spin the
chevrolet corvair monza spider most
american cars of its era boasted
oversized bodies and a big engine up
front ideally a v8 but not the Corvair
and infinity games Christoph says in the
nineteen fifty sales of European cars
rose massively in the US especially
those of the VW Beetle it was the polar
opposite of the kinds of vehicles
American manufacturers had in their
portfolios at the time suddenly its
design and technology was considered
modern progressive even hip but the
American response to this demand was
soon to arrive it came in 1959 and was
called the Chevrolet Corvair call there
by American standards the Corvair was a
compact even though at almost 4.6 meters
it's longer than a Mercedes Ponton and
its 6-cylinder boxer engine with close
to 100 horsepower didn't Wow
power-hungry American drivers that much
either but they were impressed by where
the engine was located the Chevy Corvair
was the only american car of its day
powered by a rear-engine gabby the extra
stuff says this exotic looking car was
surprisingly successful more than
250,000 rolled off the assembly lines in
the first year alone mortar trend
magazine named the Corvair car of the
year for 1960 and things got even better
when chevy introduced the Monza option
with a floor shift bucket seats larger
hubcaps and a bit more chrome God couple
of ones
it was me a cold soon Chevrolet was
selling more Monza's than standard
models the only thing missing was a
stronger engine but not for long as
Kristoff explains to listen that
violence a state cuts table in 1962
Chevrolet presented an additional option
the spider and it was truly sensational
a first series production car to feature
a turbocharged engine it's 150
horsepower propels the car from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour and 10.3 seconds with
a top speed of 165 km/h the turbo boost
is only really effective in a relatively
small range between 3,000 and 3800 RPM
but then it really kicks in to make sure
drivers could master and keep an eye on
this innovative technology the dashboard
features what Kristoff figures is likely
the first boost pressure indicator in
automotive history though it tops out at
just 0.7 bar which he finds touching
but it wasn't just the Corvairs
technology that set new standards so did
its design this accent line which wraps
around the entire car body came to be
known as the Corvair line this design
feature which visually divides the body
into upper and lower sections was later
adopted by European manufacturers like
BMW and NSU the spider came with a dash
featuring five round gauges in a brushed
aluminum instrument panel and with a
stick shift only giving it the feel of a
true-blue American sports car but as I
think Christophe says the monster
spiders real highlight lights here under
the hood it's 2.7 liter turbocharged
engine the first series production turbo
an automotive history to paddle wheels
rotate inside this casing gear driven by
the exhaust and then press the air and
gas mixture into the combustion chamber
this engine delivers up to 70 more
horsepower than the normally aspirated
one and all for a bargain price and its
day the spider package cost us 296
dollars extra it looks great
unfortunately it doesn't always work so
well it took porsche and saab to finally
tame the turbo didn't get the coke
still it's turbo technology boosted the
Chevy sales and 1962 more than 300,000
Corvairs were sold making it the most
successful year in the models history
let's get the holidays but christophe
notes that there was a small problem
with the Corvair or those who drove it
unlike the solid and steady front-engine
boats Americans were used to driving the
rear engine Corvair had a dynamic but
somewhat temperamental driving style and
some people couldn't cope with that
especially on hard turns the car's rear
would Jack up causing the wheel to tuck
under the car to oversteer and the rear
end to swing out to combat this effect
Chevrolet specified different pressures
for the front and back tires but many
buyers thought this was just a misprint
in their owners manual so the Corvair
was headed for disaster ones or
investors and in love
Chevrolet soon found itself facing over
100 lawsuits resulting from serious
accidents the automaker worked
frantically to make the car safer
modifying the suspension and adding
better drum brakes but it was too little
too late
including physique Christophe says the
Corvairs fate was sealed in 1965 when
consumer advocate and lawyer Ralph Nader
published his book unsafe at any speed
in it he called the Corvair the most
dangerous vehicle on the road sales
plummeted and a 1969 production of the
Corvair ceased entirely Christophe
thinks that's a real shame he says with
better drivers the Corvair story might
have had a happier ending besa besa all
the fun then head to the Corvair story
definitely find out what caused it to be
avin could they know still Krista feels
it's trend-setting design and its status
as the first turbocharged mass
production model make the corvair monza
spider a milestone and automotive
history in 1965 the Corvair range got a
new body and the turbocharged engine was
no longer offered quickly and quietly
Chevrolet relegated its pioneering
series production turbo model to the
history books